your last pizza probably came in a box
like this it's cardboard sturdy and most
importantly keeps your cheese from
getting stuck to a lid and that's thanks
to Domino's whose founder is widely
credited with creating the corrugated
pizza box it's just one of the company's
Innovations not in pizza but in delivery
in 2022 more than 40 percent of online
delivery orders for major pizza chains
were from Domino's here's how the
company made its name in the pizza
delivery market and why this
foundational piece of its business is
facing new challenges this is the
economics of dominoes
[Music]
Domino's originally called Dominic's
acquired its first restaurant in 1960 in
Ypsilanti Michigan and jumped into the
delivery business the same year
something very few restaurants were
doing at the time you know now we think
of deliveries being so ubiquitous I mean
so many types of restaurants have
delivery But Domino's was there very
early at scale one reason it's become so
well known for its delivery is a
campaign the company started in the 80s
promising delivery in less than 30
minutes within 30 minutes only Domino's
Pizza delivers in 30 minutes or less
people really did have the sense that
once they ordered that pizza they were
going to get it to their homes quickly
and I think that really helped for
marketing Domino's ended that guarantee
in 1993. after a delivery driver struck
another vehicle resulting in a lawsuit
but by then the company had cemented its
place and delivery and in the half
century since Domino's was founded it's
paid off
it took the biggest slice of pizza chain
sales in 2022.
Domino's success is due in part to
creativity in every step of its delivery
process starting with stores
many are small and often with little or
no dining space a model the company has
said allowed for lower rents and reduced
store expenses
over the years Domino's has also focused
on establishing more than 6 500
locations in the U.S and has worked with
franchisees to extend their reach
so I'm part of dominoes strategy is
what's called fortressing which is
making sure there's enough pizza shops
in a certain mile radius that wherever
your order goes one of those pizza shops
can handle it and it can help get it to
your house quickly the company supply
line is also structured to make the
pizza creation process as quick and
uniform as possible Domino's has 25
supply chain centers in the U.S where
dough is mixed and toppings are prepared
before being sold to franchise stores
where pizzas are assembled and baked the
more pizzas that are sold the more money
Domino's makes from its supply chain it
made up 59 percent of Domino's Revenue
in 2021.
the next part of the process is ordering
in 2008 the company rolled out its
Advanced online ordering system which
included a customized Pizza Builder and
the Pizza Tracker so the Pizza Tracker
is something that Domino's invented they
will let you know where it is in the
process it's whether it's being cooked
whether it's out for delivery where
they're approaching Domino's has
continued to introduce new ordering
options Pizza Emoji sent Domino's
ordered smiley face then there's the
last step of the process getting the
pizza from the kitchen to your home from
working with special kinds of insulated
bags to creating 3D car top signs
Domino's has been a big innovator in
this step the company has experimented
with several methods of delivery
vehicles
helicopters electric bikes self-driving
cars even cars with a heated Pizza Oven
it's really putting the whole brand
behind delivery in a lot of ways but
after years at the top of delivery
Domino's is facing new challenges
companies like ubereats GrubHub and
doordash are eating at Domino's business
in the U.S as drivers leave pizza for
apps with more flexible hours it
contributed to an industry-wide delivery
driver shortage other chains like Papa
John's and Pizza Hut have both started
working with some of these apps but
Domino's has resisted they argue that
that makes it more profitable because
you're not having to pay an outside
service to deliver that pizza and to
Market that pizza on their app and it
keeps them closer to their customers as
the company has faced these issues its
shares have slumped from a high at the
end of 2021. now Domino's is exploring
new options the company is building out
a fleet of electric delivery vehicles to
recruit new drivers and it's now
offering customers what it calls a three
dollar tip to pick up their own pie we
see you carry out Heroes you know it's
much cheaper for them if their customers
pick up their own pizza and so they are
getting in the pickup game in a big way
as Domino's continues to Grapple with
these issues investors and customers
will be watching for future Innovations
[Music]